bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end votre émission dédiée aux
loisirs et aux sorties de cette fin de
semaine dans cette émission nous
parlerons de jardin de poésie
buissonnière de calligraphie arabe
mais avant place à notre premier invité
phil gordon bonsoir vous êtes maire
adjoint à la culture manifestations de
la vie de plaisirs estivaux et en
plateau avec nous c'est évidemment pour
nous parler du festival escales
d'ailleurs qui donc a lieu à plaisir ce
samedi de 14 heures à 23 heures 30
environ
on va dire ça comme ça j'ai envie de
dire évidemment vous êtes pourparlers
discale d'ailleurs parce que c'est une
véritable institution ce festival ça
existe depuis combien de temps
c'est vrai on en est à la 13e édition
c'est une grande manifestation des plus
grandes gratuite des yvelines et donc
qui réunit environ dix mille personnes à
peu près sur la journée la soirée
donc c'est le parc du château à plaisir
pour ceux qui sont intéressés
quel est le thème de cette année parce
qu'il ya un thème tous les ans oui alors
on a un petit peu évolué au fil des
années est donc cette année c'est
principalement l'événement de fin du
spectacle qui sera bollywood qui va on
va dire à faire la tête d'affiche mais
on dit toujours c'est quand même le
festival des arts du monde donc le thème
est assez varié
musicalement parlant on sera plutôt dans
le soul funk et puis évidemment l'idée
c'est de partager de deux rencontres et
de découvrir les arts du monde
alors venez partager partager aussi avec
les associations locales qui sont très
mobilisés à cette occasion tout à fait
c'est même je dirais plébiscité chaque
année les associations souhaitent
participer et s'implique pleinement
on l'a bien sûr de façon visible sur le
pole dance ou c'est principalement des
associations qui animent le spectacle
mais aussi avec le pôle gastronomique où
vous avez la majeure partie des stands
qui consiste à faire découvrir les
spécialités culinaires de beaucoup de
personnes qui sonde était différente sur
la ville de plaisir donc vous aurez les
stand marocain les stands
africain et ses risques a d'ailleurs
effectivement la vie c'est gratuit c'est
dans le parc du château de plaisir à
partir de 14h qu'est-ce qu'on peut
retrouver comme type d'animation alors
on en a pour tous les goûts face et
orienter famille voilà exactement le
premier mot principal ces familles
l'idée c'est qu'on vienne avec ses
enfants sa famille ses amis dans quatre
pôles principaux l'epo le jeu bien sûr
pour la jeunesse avec des jeux très
interactifs très beaucoup de bois
beaucoup de visuels beaucoup de couleurs
de l'aérien vous avez après l'accord des
communs qui est plus seguin gars de plus
ce spectacle de proximité
vous avez bien sûr le pole dance et puis
le pôle musique avec la en début d'après
midi plus tôt les élèves du
conservatoire en allant après crescendo
pour les têtes des fiches en fin de
soirée hier c'est justement cette
affiche alors cette année on a un groupe
original molto de milk le lait maltais
traduction en anglais qui est un groupe
de soul funk vraiment qui a une pêche
vraiment très dynamique sur scène et
puis on finira par olic le ghost ou
bollywood donc quelque chose d'assez
magique un spectacle à base de cinéma de
danse et qui aura des projections de
scènes à laser sur les arbres autour de
la scène autour du parc du château donc
ça sera vraiment très coloré très aérien
sans les protections de clément brillant
oui exactement
donc là on a voulu aussi un petit peu
apporté une innovation donc même si on
retrouve les goodies conte à chaque
année on innove un petit peu on reste
vraiment sur la découverte et sur le la
couleur l'espace
on aura aussi des déambulations de
marionnettes géantes et on aura envie de
regarder toutes ses couleurs tout au
long de la soirée
l éducation c'est à partir de quelle
heure pour toute la journée il y aura
plusieurs scènes plusieurs séquences y
compris à la fin puisque la fin on
guidera le public vers la sortie
gentiment avec un petit défilé de ce
genre donc ça c'est toute la journée
donc il ya des animations effectivement
toute la journée on parle beaucoup de
financements évidemment des activités
est ce que sk d'ailleurs un peu souffert
on peint de baisses de subventions
d'investissement vous restez sur le même
nid
ou est-ce que vous avez dû revoir
certaines choses bon c'est vrai que ça
festival ambitieux mais beaucoup d
ambitieux il est gratuit c'est une
volonté de notre mère joséphine coleman
ce berger puisque c'est un lieu de
rassemblement de toutes les populations
de toutes les quartiers en un lieu
unique un familial donc ça c'est
important de le reconduire
on a trouvé des sources on va dire
d'économies cette année par en
optimisant un petit peu mais on n'a pas
baissé le niveau de qualité le niveau de
prestation et puis pour tout vous dire
on recherche évidemment des financements
extérieurs pour ses financements 100% à
120% ville de plaisir donc là je cherche
un petit peu si vous voulez à utiliser
les technologies modernes du numérique
l'utilisation smartphone pour avoir des
phases interactive avec les artistes par
exemple faire des petites photos et puis
les mettre sur un site bref inclure un
petit peu dans cette interactivité du
festival un côté numérique et donc en
particulier si les entreprises du bassin
de vie autour de plaisir sont intéressés
pour nous accompagner dans la mise en
place de ces nouvelles technologies
bien sûr tout en restant sur ce thème
les arts du monde
ils sont les bienvenues pour les
prochains ce style pour cette édition là
pas de bouleversement mais pour les
éditions précédentes il y aura
clairement une évolution du festival
voilà pour les prochaines voilà enfin
forcément les réduction des dotations de
l'état nous amène des économies un petit
peu dans tous les domaines
ce festival reste un élément clé sur la
ville de plaisir
donc on va le maintenir mais évidemment
avec des financements extérieurs pour
compléter un petit peu la dotation ça
veut dire que vous qui êtes maire
adjoint à la culture aux manifestations
doivent prendre une autre casquette
alors on va dire que les subventions
bah oui on est déjà en contact avec
quelques entreprises plaisir oise de
renom et puis bien sûr on élargit au
niveau des yvelines ça coûte cher ça
coûte un peu plus de deux cents 200
mille euros c'est quand même quelque
chose de très important c'est un
investissement important pour la ville
mais bon pour dix mille personnes pour
vraiment rassembler tous les quartiers
de la ville et toutes les tranches de
l'otage c'est ça qui est aussi important
on n'a pas trouvé d'autre idée que ce
festival pour rassembler vraiment tous
les plaisirs oit pour une fête
formidable au soleil quant à elle fera
encore bowie fera bravo pour ce week-end
et vous même vous avez dit avant de
l'entrée sur ce plateau que de façon à
escale à lyon il fait toujours beau
exactement combien d'associations
mobilisées et combien de bénévoles parce
que président il ya beaucoup de
bénévoles ont il ya plusieurs dizaines
d'associations j'ai pas le nombre exact
en tête qui sont impliqués directement
sur le festival / plaisir y en a à peu
près 80 des associations culturelles
mais il y en a bien la moitié qui sont
pleinement impliqués
donc c'est quand même important et ça
fait le festival en fait le festival et
le festival avant tout des plaisirs oies
et on entame de bénévoles non jeu pareil
je ne connais pas le nombre mais on va
dire que la majeure partie des gens qui
organise ce festival sont bénévoles
au delà des services de la ville
évidemment les services techniques qui
est l'installation les services
environnement propreté qui font en sorte
que le parc du château reste encore
toute la journée dans le programme et
que sinon il ya noté qu'il ya 100
poubelle c'est important de bien le dire
et bien sûr les services de la direction
des affaires culturelles ce sont les
trois services les plus impliqués que je
profite pour remercier sur ce plateau
alors un festival escales d'ailleurs
c'est gratuit c'est dans le parc du
château de plaisir à partir de 14 heures
et jusqu'à 23 heures plus tard
leurs collègues non mais ça peu avant
minuit à huy a raison il ya plus de
touristes il ya plus l'autorisation
attention ça va se transformer mais donc
de 14h jusqu'à environ 23h30 dans le
parc du château c'est un festival qui
est gratuit qui mélange de la musique de
la danse des arts de la rue des
expositions france ça fait beaucoup de
chose merci beaucoup de corps là d'être
vie serait une sorte de plateau et donc
je rappelle que ce festival est gratuit
on va ouvrir maintenant une page
exposition une exposition de
calligraphie arabe est présenté en ce
moment même à la maison félix montigny
le bretonneux l'artiste sera d'ailleurs
présent ce samedi et dimanche pour
parler de son travail
nous l'avons rencontré lors d'un atelier
il faut que le geste soit fluide est le
plus lié possible un vrai tour de main
ou de poignées pour réaliser au mieux
les traits de la calligraphie arabe
quelle que soit la taille de ce que vous
voyez là c'est fait d'un seul geste
c'est surtout des enfants les adorent ça
ils sont très doués sont très âgées
c'est parce qu'ils font ce qu'ils se
retiennent pas bon d'être est réalisée
avec un calame un roseau taillé par
lequel ils graff lui-même qu'il a juste
à sa main et à son style d'écriture
là vous avez trois sortes de canam le
calame c'est en fait c'est un roseau
taillé la calligraphie arabe elle est
née avec l'arrivée de l'islam surtout
parce que dans la religion islamique
d'imagés ben ali s'est développé
beaucoup avec l'islam et l'exister un
petit peu avant parce que l'histoire
d'écriture à bagdad du quatrième au 3e
siècle avant jésus-christ
le montana fait c'est l'art de la belle
écriture la calligraphie existe un
manque chez les arabes chez les hébreux
chez chez les asiatiques les chinois
abdelkrim ben belkacem expo son travail
jusqu'à dimanche à la maison félix de
montigny-le-bretonneux de grandes
feuilles blanches sur lesquelles ces
cris les symboles calligraphique elle
n'y a aucune phrase coranique dans ce
caveau et ça n'a rien de religieux
ce ne sont que des citations de sagesse
de d'amour de de paix l'artiste est
présent pour expliquer son travail et
les matériaux qu'ils utilisent par
exemple pour fabriquer son encre on y
trouve de la gomme arabique de la mode
de galles de la pierre d'alun pour
éviter les moisissures ou encore de la
laine de mouton qui crée une encre
appelé smac tout un savoir-faire cap tel
crime même avant tout partager
bienvenue à maquiller tv fielleux 72
défendeurs téléfilm agnes szavay
bienvenue et le plein air plein air pour
parler évidemment d'autres paroles de
jardiniers c'est reparti pour trois
week-ends du 10 8 au 13 au 28 juin et
pour en parler cible à bon soir bonsoir
alors par le jardinier faites-nous
voyager dans les jardins on va être
d'abord commencer par le plus grand que
tout ce que tous ceux qui qui
connaissent la france le connais bien je
vous laisse deviner versailles et donc
notre ami le jardinier en chef du
domaine national nous fait l'amitié de
faire des conférences donc à partir
d'après-demain le 14 donc dans le par
alain baraton alain baraton que l'on
voit en photo le matin mais c'est déjà
complet et l'après midi le reste des
places et à 15 heures avec l'aide de ces
jardiniers et on peut recevoir jusqu'à
300 personnes donc il reste juste
quelques places c'est pour ça qu'il faut
donc on vous encourage à réserver
rapidement
d'autre part dans paroles de jardinier
nous avons une clôture exceptionnelle
après on parlera de tous les petits
événements qui se trouve tout autour on
a une clôture exceptionnelle au domaine
nationale de saint germain en laye où là
il ya des tas d'ateliers des ateliers de
rempotage les plantes sous tous leurs
états ou même comment utiliser les
essences naturelles de plantes les
huiles essentielles pour se soigner ou
bien encore comment on peut pratiquer
pour aménager deux façons paysagère un
jardin ça montre c'est gratuit tout est
gratuit
tout est gratuit les ateliers sont sur
réservation mais il y as autour de tout
ça des spectacles de rue des spectacles
de cirque des petites scènes de théâtre
pour les familles et c'est vraiment un
événement qui dure toute la journée et
qui est spécifiquement réservée aux
enfants et aux familles préfèrent alors
le lit une multitude d'activités
oui on est à plus de 80
partenaires qui participent à cette
opération donc on a on à l'espace
rambouillet qui participent à
l'opération
l'espace rambouillet va nous parler de
tout ce qui est plantes aquatiques et
puis aussi delà de la cua pony et des
murs végétaux c'est très à la mode
actuellement les murs végétaux on va
nous expliquer comment ça s'organise
comment on peut les faire pousser et
c'est tous les week-end samedi et
dimanche de week-end qui arrive là
jusqu'à la fin du mois donc du 13 au 28
juin on va les côtés de chantal fleury
est depuis en cours à la découverte des
jardins familiaux
oui alors les sondés ce sont des jardins
familiaux qui ouvre exceptionnellement
au grand public ce sont des passionnés
qui font découvrir leur petit havre de
paix et par exemple celui de fontenay
est un potager bio qui ce qui se visite
et qui va proposer
comment on récupère l'eau de pluie qui
va expliquer tout ça et comment on
utilise moins d'eau pour arroser son
jardin puisque je rappelle que le thème
de parole de jardiniers c'est cdc l'eau
et c'est un peu d'eau beaucoup d'effets
non mais c'est un 14 e mail fontenay
flory et 20 juin le jardin familial de
guyancourt c'est simplement gratuit
l'association nature ville sas et sata
sartrouville
voilà alors sartrouville organise une
espèce de mini salon il ya plein
d'animations sur sur le thème des fleurs
des jardins de l'eau donc il y aura un
troc aux plantes
il y aura des ateliers et puis on pourra
discuter ensemble sur tout ce qu'on fait
dans le cas de son jardin ce jour-là à
sartrouville
20 juin voilà c'est dommage un jeu
d'argent ville une ville verte le 20
juin également
alors c'est tout à fait différente ce
qui se passe à aubergenville on va faire
une visite guidée des bords de seine
et puis on va aussi toujours le sur le
thème de l'eau c'est une sorte de visite
technique que l'on fait puisqu'on va
visiter le centre d'épuration d'eau donc
visite technique très intéressante qui
permet de savoir où vont les eaux usées
et comment tout ça est traité donc ça
c'est au père jean ville le 20 juin
toujours le 20 et 21 juin c'est à lévis
un nom alors là c'est un jardin privé et
que ce chantage même qu'aux caisses est
forcément là un côté cm suez la dame
exactement ces mêmes pays ont pas j'en
passe et pour celles qui s'en occupe et
donc un jardin privé qui n'ouvre que ce
époque ses portes qu'à de rares
occasions ils nous font le plaisir de
les ouvrir pour nous c'est l'ancienne
demeure d'andré gide et donc c'est un
couple de passionnés de jardins qui
l'ont qu'ils ont repris il est il est
vraiment ponctuée par l'oim ce jardin il
ya un grand canal qui le traversent
il y à des démarches et des sources
et cette dame le cultive avec amour et
elle vous ouvre ses grilles port tandis
qu'on veut pour vous présenter tout ça
et c'est vraiment exceptionnel et c'est
magnifique je les visite et moi même
j'en connais pas dans le coup de coeur
de celui là n'a pas conscience est parti
c'est la mivoie c'est ça en fait c'est
la bible d'accord sur le nom de la
propriété d'un niveau assez à lévis un
nom et donc c'est une visite qui aura
lieu les 20 et 21 juin par monsieur ou
madame coquet oui madame coquet qui
s'occupe des gens dont le nom est
charmant merci cette vie c'est tout en
terme de alors après il ya le site
internet son état c'est ce que je vous
ai présenté aujourd'hui il y en a 90
avec les idées ne manquent pas et on
peut être occupé tous les week-ends
gratuitement jusqu'à la fin du mois
jusqu'au 28 juin prochain donc parle de
janvier du 13 au 28 juin est important
de rappeler qu'effectivement toutes les
animations sont gratuites à sa merci
beaucoup c'est lui vous nous parliez
d'un marathon au tout début de cette
chronique et bien justement il est venu
sur le plateau du 7-8 c'était mercredi
dernier je propose l'écoutent d'écouter
un extrait de l'entretien réalisé avec
you will friedrich il nous parle de son
émerveillement sève maire vainement à
découvrir les jardins de particuliers
à l'écouter on découvre dans certaines
propriétés et dans les yvelines en
particulier des jardins sublime fait
avec la gauche inwi par des gens qui
disposent de peu de moyens simplement il
avait du temps il avait de l'amour
il avait de l'imagination donc ce n'est
pas une question d'histoire de lieu sur
les plaines question d'argent c'est
simplement une question de créativité et
dans vie de faire plaisir car c'est ça
je crois le principe même du jardin vert
se faire plaisir et faire plaisir à ses
proches jardiner c'est un briseur qui se
développe de plus en plus et ça ne coûte
pas nécessairement cher c'est ce que
vous nous dites jardiner snif c'est un
plaisir qui s'amortit très vite il y a
bien sûr un petit matériel de base à ce
concurrent
mais quand on regarde le
l'investissement cantoria bhl le rapport
le profit et quand on regarde surtout la
joie que cela offre
je vous rappelle que dans le jardin tout
le monde peut participer les jeunes et
les moins jeunes les personnes âgées les
amis donc c'est un plaisir collectif
et pour continuer ce magazine nous
partons maintenant du côté de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines puisque la
maison elsa triolet aragon propose une
opération qui s'appelle joliment baptisé
joliment poésie buissonnière un festival
pour montrer que la poésie peut
s'exprimer sous toutes ses formes et
pour cette huitième édition il ya huit
compagnies qui sont présentes et pour
nous en parler car les gourmands bonsoir
non c'est vrai directrice adjointe de
cette belle maison
comment va se passer cet après midi du
dimanche 14 juin ça se passe entre 14
heures et 18 heures 14 heures et 18
heures en fait on ouvre le parc qui fait
près de 6 hectares donc oui compagnies
comme vous le disiez donc c'est des
compagnies d'arts de rue donc les gens
flânent et peuvent picorer par ci par là
un spectacle ou deux donc quand même 10
ainsi s'ils veulent parce que il ya des
secteurs qui se répètent de temps en
temps quand même temps pour passer
spectacle alors s il ya à la fois
d'aider des compagnies qui proposent des
choses complètement en continu toute
l'après midi et donc c'est des petits
spectacles qui vont durer 10 minutes et
puis vous avez des spectacles qui ont
duré une heure donc voilà vous avez un
planning un plan du parc et vous
choisissez ce que vous avez envie de
devoir vous dites la poésie et se
décline sous toutes ses formes c'est le
thème de la poésie buissonnière c'est à
dire on ne fait pas on n'est pas là que
pour réciter des poèmes bien au
contraire voir c'est vraiment très très
différents en fait vous avez par exemple
du jonglage ou de la voltige de la danse
de la chanson voilà donc la poésie alors
elle par exemple qu'on a un institut de
beauté littéraire donc là vous allez
aller sous un casque séchoir écouter de
la poésie ou avoir un soin dans cet
institut aux couleurs vichy des années
50 voilà donc là c'est un peu surprenant
d'entendre de la poésie de cette façon
là vous allez avoir
je sais pas la guerre de 14 18 qui va
être content et par des pommes de terre
donc voilà c'est assez surprenant c'est
la guerre de 14 revu et corrigé
solidaire parce antonin l'un passionne
de pommes de terre donc de la guerre de
14 antonin c'est vraiment du du
personnage ça s'appelle poilus curé de
guerre c'est ça donc voilà il se disait
que l'abus sur de l'adami donc on va là
vous avez vous rentrez dans la guerre
14-18 comme vous n'y êtes jamais voilà
comment l avez jamais vus mais justement
on va voir un extrait tout de suite de
poilus purée de guerre
diallo
voilà la poussière
damien
on peut en faire des choses avec des
pommes de terre
surprenant tout à fait je veux tout
faire parler de la compagnie à fargues
théâtre qui propose qui revient sur
l'histoire des trois mousquetaires
alors c'est l'histoire des trois
mousquetaires ils ont ils arrivent quand
même à résumer ça en une demi heure
alors que ces trois mille pages donc
c'est quand même une prouesse et en plus
ils sont deux pour les trois
mousquetaires donc c'est des combats
d'épées et voilà et puis il ya aussi il
passe de la réalité d'aujourd'hui au
texte voilà c'est là aussi un peu un peu
parti il ya aussi une expérience assez
étrange avec un certain général de
thomert qui est ce général de thomert
c'est un gel de professeur fou voilà il
propose une machine un peu un peu
farfelu un qui permet de relancer
l'imagination voilà il trouve que
l'imagination un peu disparu du monde
actuel et donc il crée cette c'est cette
espèce de bocal un peu surprenant voilà
donc là on est vraiment sur quelque
chose de déjantés je dirais voilà
politique mais déjanté alors là on voit
quelques images mettant voir un extrait
de ce fameux gerald de thomert qu'est ce
qu'il peut faire
on peut pas trouvé ça petit peu comme
voilà donc oui j'ai mon baptême voilà
qui va aller vider la cervelle de ce
public
je lui mettrais un composant de mon
invention du liquide à quoi respirer
à
effectivement la dame elle n'est pas
très sûr la profession n'a peut-être pas
tout à fait confiant c'est aussi un
spectacle de bulles de savon alors là
ses débuts l'extraordinaire vraiment
début les normes
voilà
vraiment superbe alors il va y avoir des
déambulations avec ses bulles là mais
aussi un atelier pour les enfants où ils
pourront s'essayer à quelques bulles
également donc on voit que 700 des
spectacles très poétique et très variée
l'émotion que voulait faire sortir à
travers
en fait il faut que ce soit très ludique
voilà c'est vraiment l'idée de promenade
en famille pour un dimanche après midi
et donc voilà l'idée c'est ça c'est que
la poésie c'est comme ça c'est magique
voilà c'est une invitation au voyage en
fait dans le parc toute la poésie
buissonnière c'est ce dimanche de 14h à
18h à la maison elsa triolet louis
aragon qui est à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines qui est une
très belle maison elle-même plein de
poésie ça si tu prête très bien et les
gens pourront visiter d'ailleurs ce sera
ouvert également donc est en résidence
les gens que voilà donc c'est parfait et
l'entrée est ce qu'on est à 5 euros avec
une réduction
voilà c'est 5 euros pour les adultes 2
euros pour les moins de 18 ans et c'est
gratuit pour les moins de 3 ans voilà
donc il faut pas hésiter à venir à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ce dimanche
merci beaucoup car une voyante est
revenue sur plateau 17,8 week-end et on
va terminer cette émission avec d'autres
idées de sorties pour votre fin de
semaine on va commencer par la fête de
la ville de saint cyr l'école un village
d'irréductibles gaulois et son camp
retranché
romain s'implante au parc maurice le luc
le temps d'une journée
au programme à partir de 13 heures
défilé à 16h des courses de chars et des
combats de gladiateurs mais oui à 20h et
21h30 un concert et un dj et à 23 heures
un spectacle pyrotechnique sonorisé la
fête de la nature revu et corrigé par le
conseil municipal des jeunes de bois
d'arcy
rendez vous samedi autour du canal
paysager pour une visite guidée à 10
heures avec un botaniste et des
animations tout l'après midi autour du
canal avec des stands photos des jeux
sur le recyclage une bourse plantes et
puis toujours dans un esprit nature a
marché bio et artisanal s'installe
dorénavant tous les dimanches matins
place jacques coeur dans le quartier de
la source de riz à montigny c'est de
8h30 à 13h et puis du sport pour
terminer cet agenda avec les finales de
la coupe des yvelines de handball ce
sera samedi et dimanche au gymnase des
droits de l'homme à guyancourt
voilà cette édition de cette mythique n
est maintenant terminée je vous souhaite
une excellente fin de journée surtout un
excellent week-end très vite